dans cet immeuble parisien en apparence
tranquille
la violence scolaire fait partie du
quotidien et pour autant la petite
équipe de bénévoles chargés de
conseiller les jeunes victimes ne
s'habituera jamais à ce qu'ils entendent
des centaines de maires angoissé et
d'enfants traumatisés appelle cette
association au secours les histoires
bouleversantes ce matin co2 recueille le
témoignage de la mère d'une élève devenu
le bouc émissaire de sa classe aux
agressions physiques s'ajoutent de plus
en plus le harcèlement et
particulièrement sur facebook
après dix minutes de récit douloureux
connaissait de réconforter cette maman
démunis
la première chose à faire c'est de
signaler le harcèlement à facebook
ensuite il faut qu'elle prenne des
copies d'écran de façon à avoir des
preuves pour pouvoir porter plainte
[Musique]
l'explosion des smartphones et la mode
des réseaux sociaux encourage le
harcèlement très violent sur internet
c'est ce qu'on appelle le cyberbullying
si le premier conseil de claude aux
victimes de violence scolaire est de
briser l'omerta
souvent elles leur commande d'aller plus
loin moi je lui dise et juridiques là il
faut prendre un avocat il faut essayer
de régler cette au tribunal mais
certaines agression particulièrement
violente choc tellement les élèves
qu'ils ont du mal à en parler de vive
voix
il préfère les raconter par mail dans
les couloirs et puis les vrais
humiliation commencé en me regardant
dans les yeux elle m'a traitée de [__]
de [__] de pétasses pensant minutes
ces agressions ne concerne plus
seulement des adolescents mais aussi des
enfants de plus en plus jeunes audrey et
psychologues
à l'autre bout du fil une maman
désespérée son fils de 5 ans bien qu'une
nouvelle fois d'être agressés à la
maternelle pas encore
dans cette situation et balafré donc
après vous êtes dans votre droit tu nous
a demandé à ce que une réalité qui
concerne les 12 millions d'élèves de la
maternelle à la terminale
si la violence scolaire est aujourd'hui
un sujet préoccupant c'est que
l'agressivité est de plus en plus
visible
des adolescents qui s'amuse à filmer des
bagarres avec leur téléphone portable
des jeux qui se termine tant passage à
tabac la violence tend à devenir un
spectacle qui ne se cache plus ces
vidéos sont désormais exhibé comme des
trophées qui font froid dans le dos un
climat de violence qui provoque des
faits divers encore plus grave parce que
des collégiens apporte des armes à
l'école
en février on déplore un professeur
blessé dans la banlieue parisienne et
même un lycéen tué à bourges
c'est d'abord dans les cours de
récréation que la plupart des incidents
démarre et malgré le travail des
professeurs et des surveillants pour
contrôler les élèves à risque
la violence s'invite aussi désormais
dans les classes puis ce qui s'est passé
je nomme au moins tu le reconnais
ensuite c'est à la sortie d'école où
certains élèves sont livrés à eux-mêmes
que les affaires se multiplient
à tout juste 13 ans des enfants
s'organisent tant bande de petits caïds
qui rackettent les collégiens à la fin
des cours des affaires prise très au
sérieux par les policiers est-ce que je
crois que t'as pas bien compris t'as pas
compris tu es dans un commissariat
t'as pas compris que tu as 12 ans et
t'as pas compris talent à faire là et
que c'est pas un jeu alors pourquoi
cette agressivité gagne hôtel autant de
terrain auprès des élèves
comment est il possible d'y faire face
enquête sur cette violence qui
s'installe dans les cours de récré
dans les cours de récréation des 7000
collège de france ce qui frappe
désormais c'est la multiplication des
incidents quotidiens
tous les jours il faut éviter qu'un
petit accrochage ne dégénèrent en
violence incontrôlable un objectif
particulièrement délicat à atteindre
[Musique]
nous sommes à toulouse dans le quartier
du mirail une cité difficile où le taux
de chômage atteint 30% 3 fois plus que
la moyenne nationale est en plein milieu
de ce quartier
le collège bellefontaine avec ses 400
élèves
détention constituent le quotidien de
xavier une sorte de super surveillants à
la différence près qu'il n'est pas payée
par le collège mais par la préfecture
pour désamorcer les situations violentes
et xavier à l'oeil partout
ce matin c'est une bagarre qu'il doit
interrompre dans le jargon de
l'enseignement xavier ce qu'on appelle
un médiateur n'importe quel collège en
zone sensible temps recruté pour
s'occuper des élèves les plus turbulents
si vous aviez est un des maillons du
dispositif imaginé par le collège pour
faire baisser la violence aller et quand
la violence est exercée dans son dos
vous aviez cherche à savoir ce qu'il
s'est passé
il veut dissiper le sentiment
d'insécurité et gagner la confiance des
élèves d'accord et pourquoi le garder
alors
si celui qui vient arranger les
problèmes ou du moins trouver des
solutions avec eux savent qu'ils peuvent
venir se confier contient un problème
c'est quand ils ont repéré quelque chose
il faut une forme ans ils viennent de
même vraiment une bagarre à la sortie
pour multiplier mais celles qui sont
créés la tête on ne pourra qu'être
raquette à bellefontaine on compte en
moyenne 4 à 5 incidents par semaine ça
peut paraître conséquent pourtant depuis
que xavier est arrivé il ya trois ans la
violence dans l'établissement a baissé
de moitié grâce aux liens qu'il a su
tisser avec les élèves
mais il doit faire attention à toutes
les situations qui pourraient dégénérer
ce matin une maman n'arrive pas à
obtenir de son fils qui lui montre son
carnet de correspondance
moi je vais russe est ce une toyota lé
dr garcia d'accord et citoyens honnêtes
un moment derrière toi et moi je fais
pas je remonte de rendre un avis sur
koné génère des comme ça on réfléchit à
deux fois que tout sera fait pour toi
d'accord à vous tenir mal là je vous
explique moi ce qu'on pense pas je la
vois je lui en parle je passais la
formation et vous appels vocaux d'accord
je vais après au bout de dix minutes
vous aviez à désamorcer le conflit il
faut dire qu'il a un gros avantage sur
les professeurs il note ni ne sanctionne
les élèves
pour les parents c'est un interlocuteur
différent plus proche d'eux données
nationales saviez les neuf autres
surveillants du collège passent toute
leur journée à tenter d'apaiser les
tensions
mais parfois cela ne suffit pas car
belle fontaine accueille tous les ans
entre deux et quatre élèves renvoyés
d'autres collèges sur décision d'un
conseil de discipline des fortes têtes
qui représentent des risques
supplémentaires
c'est ce qui se passe ce matin là
bonjour lyonnais longueur le territoire
c'est pas bon jour lionel le numéro 2 du
collège se déplace en personne pour
accueillir un nouvel élève
nous l'appellerons sam ce n'est pas
n'importe qui il s'est illustré dans son
ancien établissement par un comportement
violent
bon alors déjà enchanté de vous
accueillir leur après je sais que c'est
un jeune homme qui vient de l'erea de
d'accord et donc qui vient dé rien parce
qu'il a eu un conseil discipline tout à
fait qu'est ce qui s'est passé je n'a
pas levé la main sur une preuve d'accord
au moins tu le reconnais c'est déjà vu
quoi c'est déjà bien après est-ce que ça
se fait non bon donc dans ton
établissement puisque tu a levé la main
sans professeurs forcément il ya eu un
conseil de discipline
et forcément il ya une exclusion puisque
dans la vie c'est pareil si on avait la
mainmise totale sur des personnes il y
aura forcément des suites d'accords et
ils m'ont fait savoir que tu es tu es
quelqu'un qui a les moments avait du mal
à garder ton calme d'accord alors ici
c'est clair que je vais avoir à l'oeil
je vais observer des élèves qui sont
issus d'un procès les disciplines nous
on est un établissement où tous les ans
on en reçoit 1 2 ou 3 et c'est pas si tu
veux je t'explique ses parts revenant
uniquement dans un nouveau collège dans
une nouvelle classe que par un coup de
baguette magique ça va changer ça
changera pas il y aura forcément quelque
chose à faire pour que l'on puisse
travailler ensemble d'accords voilà donc
moi j'ai entendu ton hockey et je
m'appuierai sur ce ok d'accord
alors après tout les élèves qu'on a reçu
11 qui sont qui sont venus ici
après un conseil discipline ils sont
toujours là et il avance et il progresse
donc à toutes tes chances
on va faire une petite visite il accorde
lionel travaille ici depuis plus de 15
ans il a l'habitude de gérer les enfants
difficiles que la cité de doges à dire
des mathématiques mais de manière à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas trop de gérer
d'histoire entre vous d'accord continue
non mais vingt tableaux lieu de 30 tout
individuel est suffisamment espacées
pour éviter les disputes mais aussi des
cours de récréation bien équipé pour que
les élèves se défoulent sans agressivité
donc voilà ça c'est la cour c'est là
vous aller en récréation
vous vous rangerez dans la partie qui
est là bas pour pouvoir rentrer par le
couloir qui étaient condamnées là avec
le rideau métallique des terrains de
basket un skatepark des terrains de
tennis
bon ça te paraît comment et pourtant sam
est inquiet il faut dire qu'il a repéré
un ennemi dans l'établissement oui
[Musique]
d'accord je peut te rassurer si tu veux
je peux tu expliquer deux ou trois
choses le fameux je le connais très bien
déjà c'est quelqu'un qui nous écoutent 1
c'est quelqu'un qui va faire attention à
ce qu'on va lui dire par rapport à ça et
donc s'il y avait le moindre problème
tu viens tout de suite nous voir pour
nous dire il se passe ça y est elles
problème je veux pas m'énerver je veux
pas je veux quelqu'un géré à ma place et
nous on va gérer d'accord 1
voilà allez venez
vogt a pas de souci à avoir un tel degré
d'accompagnement est rare mais il faut
dire que la situation était encore
intenable
il n'y a pas si longtemps quand tu alors
le principal adjoint redouble
d'attention pour éviter que la cocotte
minute explose
sam va donc être protégés au delà même
de l'enceinte du collège c'est ce que va
révéler lionel aux nouveaux venus
d'accord donc si on doit accompagner
jusqu'au métro photo rassurer pour
t'éviter d'avoir des problèmes on le
fait on l'a déjà fait si on doit se
trouver un moyen de t'amener même avec
un véhicule au métro on le fera on l'a
déjà fait il ya des gens pour ça le
principal adjoint l'a bien compris la
paix scolaire s'achète aussi en dehors
de son établissement et en ce sens la
menteuse les yeux dans les yeux
voilà c'est moi et puis je vous dire le
dialogue accord lundi merci au revoir
il a tout essayé
le psychologue que ce soit à l'école on
me l'a baissé les bras et j'ai dit non
je peux pas le lâcher
il est jeune ça va être dense et comme
quoi c'est pas possible
voilà
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que tu aimes faire
le compte était en loisir sur un
terrible tu te couches tard il va
s'ouvrir et que ça les rend si au niveau
scolaire et au niveau du comportement
que ce soit avec les adultes ou les
enfants
pas de souci on va vers une diversité
sur les 400 élèves du collège la
direction estime que 10 % ont un
problème de discipline durant les
récréations mais également classe des
tensions entre élèves mais aussi avec
les professeurs et les surveillants
voici un élève à risque un très jeune
ado comme jamel qui défient l'autorité
des adultes de l'établissement
il n'a que 13 ans et il a insulté un
surveillant
cet élève est le plus gros souci de
denis le principal qui a convoqué ses
parents soir une mère d'élève avec son
enfant c'est un élève qui est fait qui
pointe de caux de gros problèmes de
comportement incivilités refus de
l'autorité total c'est à dire qu'un
positionnement tout à fait indépendant
dans un établissement sans aucun respect
des règles et du règlement intérieur
jamais elle est un élément incontrôlable
le principal à une solution le placer
dans une classe où règne une discipline
de fer
mais il faut l'autorisation de sa mère
qui tarde à venir
elle a déjà trois quarts d'heure de
retard
c'est un moment clé qu'elle allait
maintenir vous ignorez passer un coup de
téléphone me il ya un refus de la
famille est certainement du jeune
premier lieu de tous les dispositifs
proposés par l'établissement c'est à
dire que là nous avons des outils mais
ces outils ne peuvent pas être utilisés
par nous parce que ces outils ne peuvent
être utilisés que si le jeune adhère
aussi la famille adhère au bout d'une
heure d'attenté ou de fil à la famille
rappelé mon collège de façon à ce qu'on
décolle ce rendez vous et pourquoi pas
se voir cet après midi voilà je vous
remercie
au revoir mais c'est assez fréquent les
parents qui qui oublient ou qui ne
viennent pas enfin qu'il soit un petit
peu de la fuite
la conseillère d'éducation et bredouille
elle en informe le principal oui staes
jusqu'à 10h30 février pour
éventuellement
tu as quoi là
anglais on va le renvoyer en cours c'est
plus simple sans attendre jamel se lève
sa mère ne viendra au collège que deux
heures plus tard face au comportement
des lèvres comme gamelle voici le type
de classe où denis le principal veut le
placer passe bien on a des garçons
[Musique]
dry dans le jargon du collège
dispositifs relais internes
ça se passe bien en clair une classe de
rattrapage pour élèves indisciplinés en
difficulté scolaire et c'est bien de se
stabiliser pour les airs tu remplis de
la même façon sauf qu'il ya deux causes
chaque fois on en compte près de 500 en
france
c'est la voie de la dernière chance mais
au kazoo djamel accepteraient d'y venir
tiendra-t-il le choc dans cette classe
deux professeurs qui savent se faire
respecter
car ils n'ont que cinq élèves alors ici
personne ne bronchent même pas l'effort
de tête jusqu'à ce qu'ils ont vu le jour
mais plusieurs offres aux sons de
journée plus que pour violences
sur l'un des fauteurs de troubles qui
reste toujours très impulsif dès la fin
des cours
malgré la tension constante des
professeurs des frictions peuvent encore
exister entre ces jeunes au caractère
bien trempé
alors pour maintenir le calme
des séances sont organisées avec
l'assistante sociale et le psychologue
du collège
c'est le meilleur moyen de bien
connaître les élèves rebelles et de
désamorcer leur accès de violence
ce jour là c'est au tour de jamel qui a
insulté un surveillant et refuse de
rejoindre la classe relais de participer
à l'atelier des coups tu sais pas
pourquoi vous êtes là
le psychologue reste neutre pour ne pas
braquer jamel et au bout de quelques
secondes
il raconte son altercation est comme ça
continue je fais de ton pas cheap de jeu
pendant 20 minutes
djamel essaie de justifier ses insultes
à l'encontre du surveillant mais aussi
son impertinence vis-à-vis des
professeurs et du coup face à lui le
psychologue va tenter de le rappeler à
l'ordre
c'est un pari de le ramener sur terre
j'arrête de faire de bêtises a tenté un
jour de changer quand même un enjeu
capot plus changé toujours une pluie de
te faire confiance je me fais confiance
dt malin tu es intelligent voilà mais
maintenant comment faire pour que toute
cette intelligence elle aille vers la
question de d'apprendre et d'arrêter se
méfier des autres et de penser que les
profs sont tous mauvais ou contre toi
monsieur bond en chirurgie
ok mais tu te le dis comme ça il faut et
cynique du couple aime ça bon alors
d'habitude à nous ce qu'on souhaite ne
pas vous regarde
mais si vous êtes est ce qu on se
reverra en continu
il
[Musique]
en effet on leur demande pourquoi ils
sont là mais c'est assez marrant de voir
comment ils oublient qu'ils ont du mal
de le dire c'est pas qu'ils oublient à
mon avis ils ont beaucoup de mal à en
parler
face aux autres djamel va-t-il réussir à
dépasser ses émotions et à s'insérer de
nouveau dans l'école la tranquillité de
l'établissement dépend du comportement
de ce genre d'élève
puis c'est au tour de xavier deleu
prendre entre quatre yeux et là le
discours est différent des capacités le
bazar à des capacités
j'en comprends c'est quelqu'un qui nous
savons déjà en fait les dommages il
s'énerve
dommage ils gâchent les choses bougent
j'ai envie de me rattraper dans les
temps la trappe et donc dans l'ordre
c'est quoi dans l'ordre c'est en classe
et en classe c quoi maintenant j'écoute
je crée la leçon je m'en mords de poids
wave 3 je pense et c'est de participer
citer 1 contrarie effet comment tu
réagis tu vas me voir d'accord
j'ai plus qu'à profiter de le voir lundi
selon jean veut plus qu'assez peu vais
me voir me disant j'ai du mal ay
m'énerve on sait pas ce qu'on va faire
de lui et que c'est tara etc
djamel semble avoir été remis sur le
droit chemin par xavier mais
tiendra-t-il toutes ses promesses
il est toujours dans la limite ce qui
des barbarians à chaque fois il va
provoquer va provoquer où il va chercher
un petit peu et
parfois il va le dépasser mais bon ça
fait des insultes m je mettrai physique
voyager oui mais voilà il a conscience
de ça parce que souvent il regrette ce
qu'il fait ou ce qui parfois pour gérer
les élèves violents
le personnel des collèges ne suffit plus
[Musique]
à la brutalité des bagarres
à la multiplication des règlements de
compte s'ajoute désormais le fléau du
racket à la sortie des écoles
c'est l'agression qui a le plus augmenté
ces dernières années un bond de 65%
depuis 2007
dans toutes les grandes villes de france
comme ici à paris la préfecture de
police a sorti les grands moyens pour
s'attaquer à la violence des enfants
à quelques pas de montmartre dans le 18e
arrondissement une unité spéciale a été
créée la brigade locale de protection de
la famille en tout sept enquêteurs
spécialisés et parmi eux le major odile
tu alcon actuellement elle travaille sur
un dossier hors norme une incroyable
affaire de racket
tout est parti de cette photo récupérée
sur un réseau social
un gang d'enfants ou le plus jeune a 12
ans et le plus vieux à peine seize au
total une douzaine d'adolescents
particulièrement violents comme le
montre leur accoutrement de petits caïds
donc ces personnes qui sont sur les
photographies sont porteurs de d'armes
de 6e catégorie à savoir
pour mme lacrymogènes de baseball si le
major a pu récupérer ces photos c'est
grâce à une de leurs victimes âgées de
12 ans qui a porté plainte et elles ont
de quoi surprendre le major falcon qui
n'avait jamais vu ça jusqu'ici
je rappelle qu'à chicago on est bien en
france et que c'est pas ce phénomène qui
est fréquent pas fréquent est ce qu'il
est encore moins c'est la violence dont
ils sont capables
le major alcon a entre les mains la
plainte du garçon de 12 ans qui a été
rackettés et qui confirme l'agressivité
du gang que j'ai déjà vu qu'ils avaient
dans leur poche ou dans leur sac des
bombes lacrymogènes
les petites instructeur d'écouteurs des
couteaux des brise vitres il cache même
une batte de baseball j'ai entendu dire
à des jeunes de mon quartier de venir
dans le square park
pour ce faire des beaux loos alors des
voleurs et des faibles alors jardin
la bande se comporte comme un petit
commando qui est suspecté d'avoir commis
de nombreuses actions violentes s'est
passé ils ont vraiment été dans un stade
se sont vendues au fait des molosses
et parmi ces beaux losc a donc il ya des
projectiles qui elle seule venue déposer
pâques alors que les autres n'ont pas
osé non mais combien de quatre ou cinq
jeunes mais les autres n'ont pas osé
déposer plainte parce que les victimes
autre a peur des représailles
grâce à la photo le major a réussi à
identifier tous les mineurs de la bande
elle pense même avoir repéré les leaders
deux frères de 12 et 13 ans déjà connu
des services de police pour être au fait
la plainte
odile falcone a besoin de preuves
supplémentaires afin de présenter à la
justice un dossier solide pour mener les
enquêtes sur le terrain elle peut
compter sur les policiers en tenue du
commissariat ils patrouillent en vtt ce
qui les rend plus mobile face au jeune
racketteur plusieurs cas de racket et
d'intimidation c'est le brigadier-chef
cyr et ses hommes qui vont patrouiller
aux alentours des établissements
scolaires du quartier
en espérant tomber sur le gang des
racketteurs
les policiers repèrent deux jeunes
postés près des grilles font-ils partie
du gang
leur présence est suspecte à cette heure
les adolescents devraient être en cours
les complots musique ce fait nous
filmons le contrôle en caméra cachée je
ne ferme pas le jeu c'est qui ton combat
moi sont pas nombreux
[Applaudissements]
mais toi tu n'es pas au collège t ou
alors un look n'a plus d'école elle tant
cherché si on cherche une monte à laon
film control vous partez pas peur ça
qu'on veut voir personne qui traînent
des abords de l'établissement d'accords
eu des petits soucis donc je voulais
attendre vous allez au square tout ça il
vous retrouvera toute fin de journée
ce tour c'est fini on n'est pas mauvaise
pioche
il ne ressemble à aucun des ados de la
photo du major d'alcool alors la
patrouille repart en quête des
racketteurs
à la sortie d'un autre établissement
scolaire le brigadier-chef est
interpellé par une maman affolée son
fils vient d'être agressé par une bande
de jeunes n'ont rien pu mais il a fallu
que votre corps et vous allez au moins
de faire une main courante signaler les
faits parce que parce que vous n'êtes
pas la première à le dire c'est pour ça
que nous avons c'est que nous on vient à
beaucoup plus souvent l'art et on veut
que ça c est quoi cette fois le
brigadier ces hommes sont arrivés trop
tard
l'enfant serait la dernière victime du
gang des racketteurs ils ne doivent pas
être loin les policiers reprennent leurs
patrouilles dans l'espoir de les trouver
et subitement au poids d'une rue la
patrouille repère deux jeunes adossé à
la grille d'un immeuble et policiers les
reconnaissent immédiatement tous les
deux figures sur la photo des cailloux
en herbe
après les avoir fouillé sans succès le
brigadier-chef commence par les
interrogés de façon anodine sur leur
scolarité
les enfants semblent coopératif mais les
policiers savent à qui ils ont affaire
et le policier va chercher à obtenir
leurs aveux sans éveiller leurs soupçons
ya les gens qui commencent à se prendre
le chou pour nous s'est-il groupe-là
kaki qui fait plein de vols issus
d'affaires il ya des vols là qu'ils se
produisent des vols sur des jeunes est
apparente amour du rock du raca toi là
ils se mettent à 10 contre 1 contre des
petits et donc un son pas avoir beaucoup
de courage je pense pas
c'est du n'importe quoi ça je joue pas
très bien communiqué les jeunes jouent
les parfaits innocents
l'hallali le brigadier-chef n'est pas
due il finit par les mettre en garde
d'accord et en plus à la fin mars a fini
par une garde à vue une prison c'est la
garde à vue
amusant amusant lagarde
après dix minutes de discussion est
toujours sans aucune preuve
les policiers doivent les laisser partir
et ils vont continuer à les surveiller
de près et accumuler des indices pour le
dossier du majeur alcon les deux les
deux plus petits les deux plus petits
ceux qui on sent qu'ils sont un petit
peu aguerri par par la rue en courant ou
en tout cas pas parler par les groupes
qui se sont constitués ils savent ils
savent répondre on n'est quand même pas
un importe qui on est la police ils
peuvent vous soutenir un petit peu
regard ils peuvent trouver des réponses
toujours adéquates à nos questions qu'on
pose mais à mais on a bien l'impression
que si on gratte un petit peu c'est si
un petit peu plus de pression on
retrouvera on retrouvera des enfants ce
jour là les policiers ne les ont pas
surpris en flagrant délit mais l'
enquête va s'accélérer ils ne le savent
pas encore
le procureur vient de donner son accord
pour que le major alcon auditionnent les
deux frères qu'ils viennent de contrôle
et on va les entendre comme la procédure
l'exigé sur leur identité leur état de
santé sur leur scolarité sur leur
situation familiale pour voir un peu ce
qui se passe au sein de la famille
pourquoi si jeune ils commettent des
infractions des infractions qui peuvent
leur faire encourir jusqu'à cinq ans de
prison
mais avant de parler de sanctions le
major veut comprendre ce qui se passe
dans leur tête d'adolescent
ils seront convoqués très prochainement
commissariat une audition qui va
réserver bien des surprises aux majors
il faut pas que ces deux mineurs sous
prétexte qu'ils ont commis ces
infractions pense qu'ils vont faire qui
vont devenir des caïds
il faut savoir temporiser les choses et
justement à faire de la prévention avec
eux beaucoup de prévention
l'opa de la sanction faire de la
prévention
c'est à dire éviter que les élèves ne
passe à l'acte cette préoccupation
taraude aussi bien les policiers
spécialistes des mineurs peut tous les
responsables des collèges et ce matin à
bellefontaine
lionel le principal adjoint n'a qu'une
obsession éviter que sam l'élève expulsé
de son ancien collège pour avoir frappé
un enseignant de récidive
alors avant de l'accueillir il organise
une réunion au sommet je suis versé 2
minutes on fait un point sur comment va
accueillant mon avis sur un truc
justement autour de la table car l'uci
le futur professeur de sam javier
l'éducateur relais que ainsi qu'un
surveillant de notre ensemble ils
élaborent leur stratégie que je suis
c'est un jeune qui pose des soucis
je dirais de comportement il sort de ses
gonds il est capable voulait été exclu
pour avoir mis un coup de poing un
professeur par contre on m'avait dit
qu'il était dans le déni de devons
reconnaître tout ça alors que moi il m'a
il m'a dit clairement que c'était vrai
et que bon il avait compris vont enfin
bref il a fait un travail de deuil
donc ça à voir c'est une information à
voir pour pour l'accueillir lors ensuite
les craintifs
donc j'ai besoin qu on verrouille le
fait que ces allées et venues ce voile
entre guillemets sécurisé verrouiller
ses allers venues c'est surtout
surveiller les nuits de sam le fameux jp
celui qu'il a déjà menacé les parties
et ce n'est pas une mince affaire car
les deux ados se haïssent et tout peut
arriver
alors lionel a décidé de prendre jp
entre quatre yeux pour le mettre en
garde
j'ai reçu un jeune qui va être
scolarisés ici ils te connais tu vois
qui c'est toi ouais bon juste une
question toit pour tu le connais tout
est carré toi je travaille comme quoi et
en primaire il ya eu des soucis il y
avait des choses particulières ce qui
les angoisse de voir ce problème et tu
le vois pas des fois du côté de cugnaux
villeneuve tolosane plus qu'à voilà moi
je voulais te dire que j'ai reçu sa
maman et lui ont ils m'ont fait part de
leur inquiétude moi je leur ai dit que
je connaissais bien en plus c'est vrai
et que j'avais complètement confiance en
toi et que je n'étais pas quelqu'un qui
se posait des soucis je veux le
principal adjoint n'a pas mâché ses mots
et jp ne moufte pas pour lionel c'est
plutôt bon signe
si au moins il sait que là il s'engage
en disant oui monsieur a joué un certain
un certain rôle voilà après je ne sais
pas ce qui se passe en dehors mais bon
oui j'ai confiance en lui
il a confiance en nous donc je pense que
ça se passera
les chapitres reste une dernière étape à
ne pas rater réussir l'intégration de
sam dans sa nouvelle classe et ça se
joue dès le premier jour sa place a déjà
été préparé et ne doit rien au hasard
entre une jeune fille sans histoire et
un élève studieux
dernière incertitude sam va-t-il
respecter cette jeune professeur
quelques minutes plus tard
c'est le principal adjoint en personne
qui va faire les présentations
[Musique]
tiens ta place tu peux aller tu as peur
d'avoir tu veux leur dire quelque chose
non on va s'installer je compte sur vous
vous soyez accompagnants j'espère à
peine lionel parti lui si l'enseignante
le prend en main un peu le résumé mais
vraiment très rapidement pour bien
affirmer son autorité et montrer que ça
ne l'effraie pas
lucie son professeur se rapproche de lui
et vient établir le contact
tu as juste au dessus un tour et si tu
réponds à une phrase complète enfin la
phrase complète tu te sers d'amour de la
question points
mais au sein de la classe tout n'est pas
aussi simple pour sam
certains élèves ont une façon bien à eux
de l'accueillir un petit coup des pôles
qui semble accidentelle mais surtout une
façon de montrer qu'il n'est pas
complètement ici chez lui
voilà qui a toutes ses chances d'avoir
un bon comportement
on a déjà eu l'année dernière un
quatrième qui est arrivé comme ça un
élève de 4e maintenant qui est arrivé
comme ça en milieu d'année avec un passé
un petit peu lourd et il se trouve ses
élèves qui a fait dix stations
maintenant donc je compte que ce soit la
même chose et on fera tout pour pour les
berceaux
si sam bénéficie de l'attention de son
professeur en classe il reste encore
bien isolé à la récréation
la stratégie de bellefontaine c'est à la
fois de surveiller les fortes têtes à
l'intérieur du collège mais aussi de
traquer les élèves qui font l'école
buissonnière
car s'il traîne dans la cité ils
risquent ensuite d'introduire au collège
de la violence de la rue pour prévenir
ces dérapages
denis le principal a décidé d'aller
chercher ces rebelles c'est xavier qui
est chargée de cette mission qui est
loin d'être simple
vous allez voir que pour récupérer ses
élèves xavier doit se rendre seul dans
des quartiers difficiles et parfois
directement dans des familles où la
tension est vive
ce jour là la collégienne qu'il va
chercher s'appelle rosa et ça fait plus
d'une semaine qu'elle manque les cours
une adolescente en décrochage scolaire
avec de gros problèmes de comportement
après de la diaconie violente maintenant
dans ses réactions dans ces mots oui
elle est violente
si nous les adultes les responsables on
abandonne
il n'y a pas d'exemple pour eux mais
c'est quoi ce ont baissé moins
franchement comme ça
c'est besson
soit un champ ne peut pas les laisser
ses enfants ils comprennent pas tout ils
ont pas réellement conscience de tout ça
donc
brel of pas pour les lâche pas
voilà
pas sûr que xavier arrive à la
convaincre de revenir au collège rosa
est issu d'une famille en situation
précaire des gens du voyage qui se sont
sédentarisés première incertitude
adolescente qui traînent souvent dans la
rue est elle bien chez elle
[Applaudissements]
je vois gérard wey sur trois ouais je
sais mais ça répond pas pour établir le
premier contact avec la famille xavier
souhaite un peu de discrétion sur ce que
je fais je viens vous voir monsieur des
merceron voix vous voir en fait ce matin
tu étais bientôt l'association d'accord
y'a pas le lundi matin et l'après-midi
d'essence et venir au collège
javier interpelle alors la mère de rose
à une arène enfin une heure et demie
heure et demi donc quand tu portes après
travaux avec moi au collège en fait non
d'accord mais si al qaîda rendez vous
chez le médecin
à quelle heure tu vas pas le temps de
jeu la prise a senti la reporter à aller
non je ne boude pas mais si tu peux bien
sûr on peut regarder intéressant lé
dakor jeu comme quoi le reporter jon
expliqué madame moi je dis oui tu vas
rentrer ça marche j'attends
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si la mer est convaincu
rosa elle ne se laisse pas faire mais en
pourparlers vous aviez va alors
bénéficié de l'aide du grand frère qui
se manifeste au premier étage
la menace de son grand frère va avoir de
l'effet rosa acceptent de retourner au
collège avec xavier m'a fait perdre un
quart d'heure de monde parle pourquoi
pourrais tu fais des fichiers non sur
partir du collège a pas de problème
[Applaudissements]
spectacle tout le monde est sorti ça
l'adolescente mais son casque elles se
coupent de plus en plus du monde
extérieur garde
mais voilà comme rosa a traîné elle va
arriver en retard au collège et ces
cours ont déjà commencé javier va donc
l'emmener directement chez le principal
adjoint
et si lionel veut la voir ce n'est pas
seulement pour son absentéisme mais
parce qu'elle a commis une grosse bêtise
trois choses il y a quelques jours rosa
est allé récupérer de force son
téléphone portable que la direction lui
avait confisqué résultat elle doit
passer en conseil de discipline dans
quelques heures
comment j'ai fait venir c'est pas pour
rigoler c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
journée importante pour l'interroger
lionel va bénéficier de l'aide de cet
homme
en fait c'est le frère de rose à celui
qui l'a poussé à aller à l'école
d'accord il est venu s'assurer qu'elle
ne s'enfuira pas avant son conseil de
discipline
le conseil est d'accord si elle n'est
pas présente
forcément ça c'est un impact très
négatif
d'accord donc l'objectif c'est que on
trouve des solutions avec parce que
depuis le temps qu'on travaillait
ensemble n'a jamais été aussi présente
que cette année cette année elle a été
présent et donc le but du jeu c'est
qu'on finisse l'année parce qu'elle est
en 3e pour trouver une solution
donc c'est pas parce que tu passes en
conseil de discipline qu'il faut pas
venir et qu'il faut se dire c'est fini
justement l'objectif là c'est comment on
termine les quatre mois qui restent au
conseil de ce soir
le principal adjoint fidèle à sa
stratégie plaidera contre l'exclusion
difficilement en dépit des circonstances
il souhaite que rosa s'accroche et
termine sa scolarité au sein du collège
l'objectif de ce conseil après je ne
peux pas juger de ce qui s'y passera
puisque je sais te kiffe rendre une
décision après avoir écouté toutes les
situations évoquées là mais c'est de ces
deux de lui montrer qui est un cadre
avec des limites et qu' on est là pour
pour les respecter sinon bah c'est ce
n'est pas jouable
à l'heure prévue le conseil de
discipline commence pour rosa c'est le
moment de vérité
elle va devoir s'expliquer sur son
comportement mais sans la présence de
notre caméra pour ne pas troubler les
délibérations
aujourd'hui rosa est en section
professionnelle avec pour moitié des
cours théoriques et pour moitié en
apprentissage tout sûrs et menuiserie ci
allait renvoyer la jeune fille met en
péril son avenir
une heure plus tard le verdict tombe
rose a le droit de rester au collège et
peut continuer de suivre sa formation
professionnelle mais elle ne peut plus
assister aux cours théoriques qu'elles
perturbent trop par son comportement
peut avoir notre chance on a war on a
droit de trébucher on a droit de faire
une erreur et qu'ils ont un droit aussi
de de repartir du bon pied ou de trouver
savons rien n'est jamais définitivement
c'était c'était vraiment compliqué hein
la situation est délicate situation il
faut pas vraiment pourquoi quand la
charge minimum sur les ateliers parce
que sinon elle va exploser et à sortir
dans la rue et sera plus scolarisés
c'est là dessus qu'on a appuyé pour
d'accord car la prochaine fois ce sera
l'éviction complète et définitive du
collège
cette année il n'y a eu qu'une seule
expulsion à bellefontaine
ce que redoute lionel et denis c'est
qu'une fois dehors ces enfants file un
mauvais coton
dans la rue la violence à laquelle ils
sont confrontés est sans commune mesure
avec ce qui se passe dans les écoles
à paris au commissariat du xviiie
arrondissement
le major odile d'alcool en sait quelque
chose elle est chargée d'enquêter sur un
gang d'enfants qui sévit dans son
quartier raquette règlement de comptes
violence ils auraient passé à tabac cinq
enfants et l'un d'eux a porté plainte
après les avoir reconnus courte alcon
c'est une journée capitale
elle a convoqué avec leur mère les deux
jeune meneur de la bande
ceux qui ont été contrôlés par les
policiers à vélo
l'autre jour pour commencer c'est le
plus grand qui passe sur le grill
il a 13 ans et sa garde à vue vous allez
le voir
on commence en douceur mais le ton va
très vite se durcir oui y'a pas chaud ou
froid
je partirai ton et chats l'adolescent
risque cinq années de prison pour
violence volontaire en bande menacé
raquette à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
de son collège à cet instant ils
ignorent encore que la police détient la
photo où il s'affiche armés l'audition
commence comme pour tous les mineurs
c'est la loi elle sera filmée et hélas
non à tapas dit pourquoi tu étais là
pour ça pour ça quoi quand les plaintes
et les plantes de quoi pour du beurre
pour des produits bons gars pourquoi tu
me regardes pas quand je te parles tu as
du mal
à supporter le regard de l'autre
pourquoi je suis pour tu as l'impression
que je te fais quoi là rien au ballon
donc ça va être facile mais tout le
temps mais tout le temps te regarde
comme ça tu regarde jamais les gens qui
te parle
pourquoi pas peur d'eux moi je peux plus
et ben alors sa peur qu'on ne te crois
pas alors est-ce que je frissonnais ce
qui s'est passé au mois de janvier
au début du mois de janvier lui on est
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé puisque je me
suis alors est-ce que tu l'a menacée non
je ne vais pas le messie alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé est ce que tu lui as dit
aujourd'hui j'ai parlé oui mais qu'est
ce que tu lui as dit continue à parler
puisque jouer comme tous âges qui l'a
dit donc lui il dit que fut la vie pour
va te tuer on va te [__] t'es mort que
tu le menacent la porte ou dans la rue
au collège au square au stade
en fait à chaque fois tout leur encontre
tu me l'as qui doivent être qu'il a déjà
également frappé à coups de poing et à
coups de pied
alors qu'est ce que tu as à me dire de
structure entoure du minaret la mesure
se sentant pris au piège l'adolescent de
13 ans se mure dans le silence pour le
faire parler le major va devoir changer
de stratégie à numéroter les élus mettre
un peu plus de pression à l'orge et
expliquer quelque chose pour l'instant
été placés en garde à vue
voilà ça veut dire que tu as 13 ans et
que déjà tu vas être connue là dedans
alors c'est pas terrible
ce que tu l'as déjà frappé lui donc tu
reconnais que tu le mets n'est ce pas et
il reconnaît qu il a déjà frappé et tu
sais pas pourquoi on est d'accord je
sais pas comment je sais pourquoi à tous
c'est pourquoi m alors pas exclu
ballanger pour balancer quoi qu'on en
dise un truc une balance le jeune garçon
utilisent déjà le jargon des malfaiteurs
mais le major a obtenu un début d'aveu
alors elle emploie à nouveau la douceur
pour inciter l'enfant a parlé je prends
des doubles mais de la façon dont tu te
comportes avec j'appelle ça pour arriver
à ses fins elle va même tenter de jouer
sur son sentiment de culpabilité en
faisant référence à sa maman qu'il
attend dans le couloir avec son frère à
temps mais quand même de savoir quel est
le commissariat pour vous 2 8 1 et
comment tu crois qu'on peut faire pour
que ça s'arrange
vale couche pas j'arrive je pense qu'on
a bien saisi l'importance et choses et
peut par contre au niveau éducatif bas
il ya beaucoup de choses à revoir et
répond fermement s'adresse à des adultes
comme si ça dans cette bande de copains
allaient voir les auditions vont se
succéder pour l'aîné des deux frères
au total il y en aura 3 1 après midi
marathon qui devrait lui faire passer
l'envié de revenir sur la c'est du moins
ce qu'espère le major d'alcool et les
policiers de la brigade
cela fait déjà quatre heures que les
deux jeunes racketteurs sont au
commissariat le major va maintenant
auditionné le frère cadet que sa mère a
accompagné mais elle ignore que la tâche
va être encore plus difficile
normal de sarria crois que c'est normal
dans un commissariat
ah bon battue dit que tout va bien tu es
content d'être là toi plus tard hier c
était dans un commissariat mercredi
après midi où il fait beau et que tu
pourrais faire du foot l'école je leur
ai no comment aujourd'hui je devais
gérer et quel effet que ça te fait
d'être viré de l'école a fait pendant
qu'un show alors c'est quoi
on va en profiter pour voir les copains
on ne peut même pas mal a réagi maman
comme elle a réagi maman tu as pu ni
tags ont des ailes fait durer le silence
en attendant que l'enfant crack mais
rien n'y fait je sais pas
c'est rien alors je me demande même si
tu sais pourquoi tu es là tu as dit mon
collègue et moi pourquoi tu es là tu te
rappelles alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé le 3 janvier 2012 sera pas celle
de l'époque louis il s'est bien passé
donc en gros tu en train de me dire que
tu vas à la directrice elle que vire de
l'école pour rien dois je vis du parti
le parti va falloir lui s'appelle
comment mais alors où est le parti -
survenu sur la façon de vendre ou de
courage à l'heure qu'il est un menteur
c'est ça donc c'était un menteur
la directrice d'école et à moteur le
surveillant est un menteur je veux
lamandi réserver la maman était une
menteuse et finalement il n'y a qu'eux
et qui sont pas des monteurs suis dit
que ça fait un an que ça dure
ah non ouais mais tu lui donnes des
coûts point d'écouté dans la cour quoi
ouais
à tout juste 12 ans l'enfant tient tête
aux majors depuis plus de vingt minutes
il nie tout en bloc et va même hausser
le ton face à la policière alors et tu
lui dis aussi des paroles pas très
gentil tu es le menace de mort de mon
écoute alors on va faire un tout quitter
c'est la dernière fois que quand je te
pose une question tu parles plus fort
que moi d'accord d'accord ou pas
d'accord
lui oui madame voilà alors est ce que tu
as dit des menaces
voilà jusqu'à présent le plus jeune des
frères n'a rien avoué alors ultime
manoeuvre elle va utiliser la photo pour
essayer de prouver sa complicité avec la
bande
donc tu veux faire croire que je connais
personne de ces gens que je vais te
montrer non rien
ça revient alors vas-y je serai prêt non
tu connais pas leur prénom non plus donc
tu connais rien en fait tu fais des
photos avec un groupe de jeunes était co
navigation pour impressionner le jeune
garçon le major appelle à la rescousse
au sein de ses collègues qui me
connaissent ils ne connaissaient
savaient qu'on les avait arraché qui m'a
dit voilà je te connais tu me sembles
notamment pour des cons maintenant et on
a autre chose à [__] dirait que tu
connais pas y tu connais alors dites moi
je les connais pas mais devant maman si
le responsable reconnaît tout le monde
hein je préfère ça se passe comme ça on
va le faire comme ça
[Musique]
l'adolescent a été beaucoup plus retors
que son frère aîné emile majors ni son
collègue nous réussit à le faire craquer
en faisant intervenir sa mère la
policière espère provoquer un déclic et
obtenir les aveux de l'enfant c'est
choquant pour d'avoir des photos comme
ça sur facebook souviendra surtout que
j'aurais bel esprit qu'est ce que
j'étais autres collègues je vous dis
l'adresse ip la police pour la couleur
perd en deux minutes
je suis désolé non faits graves c'est
grave mais surtout elle a l'impression
de perdre son temps encore ce qu'elle
considère comme une broutille ce matin
ça devient trop facile maintenant dès
qu'ils ont un pet de travers à les
reprendre la police moi j'ai d'autre
part à perdre du temps à perdre
autrement j'ai plein d'activités j'ai
plein de trouvailles
je vous demande de patienter un petit
peu avec je vais sortir toutes les
auditions que vous pourrez partir avec
je veux sortir les auditions
d'accord qui peut attendre donc loi avec
ta maman pas sauter le temps que je vous
ressortez la paire est parti pour
l'instant aux médecins et parce que
c'est normalement la garde malgré tout
ces auditions la mère n'a toujours pas
pris conscience de la gravité des faits
je trouve que c'est complètement nul
est-ce que de tout de toutes générations
les enfants se sont toujours battus
entre eux donc si tous les parents du
monde s'amusait à aller porter plainte
parce qu'il ya eu une base parce qu'il
ya eu un un mot clope autres on s'en
sort pas quoi je pense qu'il ya des
choses plus urgentes
plus grave qu'une bagarre entre enfants
c'est la peur que demain de les voir
voir nos enfants se prennent pour des
caïds
alors que je qu'une simple garde à vue
le fils aîné lui semble avoir retrouvé
son âme d'enfant
il s'amuse avec un jouet après cette
longue après-midi au commissariat
le message est peut-être passé alors le
plus jeune n'a pas trop saisi pourquoi
il était là et le plus ancien la mer
[Musique]
mais non elle a déjà pris des mesures
puisqu'elle est suivi avec un juge
un juge qui est chargé de suivre la
famille en raison du comportement
difficile des enfants
la garde à vue du grand frère n'est pas
prolongé et tout le monde peut donc
maintenant rentrer à la maison
l' enquête pénale elle se poursuit leur
complice ceux de la photo seront
entendus à leur tour et en fonction des
éléments le procureur décidera ou non
d'engager des poursuites
chaque année plus de 80 mille mineurs
sont présentés devant un juge
d'instruction qui les rappels à l'ordre
parce que le plus souvent ils se sont
retrouvés livrés à eux mêmes dans la rue
[Musique]
une situation contre laquelle se bat
tous les jours le collège bellefontaine
cet après midi là il est 16h30 c'est la
fin des cours mais pour xavier la
journée n'est pas finie
comme promis il va raccompagné sam
jusqu'au métro
souvenez vous c'est le dernier élève
arrivée au collège il craint de croiser
l'un de ses anciens ennemis ou alors
cette journée doit bien savait comment
il allait elle est bien comment se faire
des copains sait pas trop ce qu'on pense
au fait tu pensé quoi que tu arrivé ici
[Musique]
je pense et ça devrait se passer
pourquoi c'est par rapport à ce qu'on
dit du collège
la rumeur tu vois les opérations faut
souvent un bon ça va bien se passer pour
toi bon à prendre
voiture
on doit rassurer moment ce soir alors tu
veux dire quoi ouais je défais des
copains tu dépends nuit
retrouvez un merci d'accord on sera
témoin tu remplis ton carnet comme il
faut sa marge et homer potence it avec
adam ça allait se passer dès le premier
jour il a écrit quelques affinités avec
certains qui sont des leaders positif
par établissement qui sont pas trop axé
sur la violence ou toujours le jeu etc
si on le laissait tout seul au milieu
d'une cour de 400 élèves qu'elle soit
qu'ils ne connaissent personne ce qu'ils
soient accompagnés etc
voilà là on irait tout droit dans le mur
c'est sûr c'est sûr donc on a réussi
dans un premier temps à l intégrer une
intégration pourtant encore fragile
xavier l'équipe de bellefontaine devront
garder un oeil sur sam comme ils le font
après les cours auprès de tous les
élèves pour éviter qu'ils n'aillent
traîner dans la cité saviem multiplie
les activités dans le collège et il y à
une discipline qui lui tient
particulièrement à coeur
la boxe française
salut aux plages pour le sol
[Musique]
stp joie ok tous eu tous les deux par
deux avec le partenaire sabrina en face
de moi on les déplace on se déplace on
va chasser
je touche avec une main dans sa jeunesse
xavier a été plusieurs fois champion de
france de ce sport de combat
ici pas question de faire n'importe quoi
la boxe a ses règles et xavier fait en
sorte qu'elle soit respectée
les élèves ne doivent jamais se faire
mal ils apprennent à retenir leurs
gestes et à se maîtriser
et puis des valeurs les valeurs de la
boxe française du mois voilà donc c'est
le respect du partenaire ont fait tôt
soit pas lui faire mal
ok stop matelas toutes les touches
depuis je vais donner avant d'être
doublé g1 la face de moi
on y va les demain eux deux un petit
doublé secours attirent essentiellement
des filles elle ne le cache pas pour
elle il s'agit d'apprendre un sport de
défense
d'accord ensuite ça moi je le mets deux
points mais deux pieds doublé on suivait
vièmes jeux tête avec plaisir sur un
revers la jambe avant par deux semaines
voilà parés de l'autre côté voilà
toujours pour l'échauffement on
recommence à la main tac le revers par
dessus ma main le côté pareil dans un
quartier
donc ouais c'est clair qu'il faut savoir
se défendre mais bon à ce que je sache
ya pas de bagarre et a pas d'histoire
dans le monde court donc ça va mais ça
les rassure
d'après xavier le grand avantage de la
boxe c'est de permettre aux jeunes de
canaliser leur agressivité
[Musique]
il sensibilise à un sport même club haut
en zone d'éducation prioritaire pour
maintenir le plus longtemps possible les
élèves au collège les activités extra
scolaires sont un élément capital pour
faire baisser la violence
et malgré tous les efforts de l'équipe
du collège
parfois un élève peut déraper ce matin
le principal à la mine déconfite
un jeune de 13 ans vient d'agresser
physiquement un surveillante et il ne
s'agit pas de n'importe qui mais de
jamel souvenez-vous celui qui refusait
d'aller dans la classe relais
spécialisés pour élèves difficiles
un inculte dans l'établissement j'ai dû
rêver automatique
bien
son foulard
ça se discute pas c'est la loi il ya
même pas matière à discussion ce cadre
là
pour récupérer un bâton il a reconnu en
conseil de discipline cette fois ci les
chances d'empêcher l'expulsion de jamel
sont minces et le principal vit très mal
tout élève qui est exclu de son collège
c'est un échec
c'est la somme quantité d'efforts de
tout le monde de toute l'équipe qui va
l'eau réduite à néant sur un geste
voilà un échec
donc je donne la boîte de la fiche de
suivi tu vois ça a été prof
d'accord on fait un point ce soir à 4
heures oui avec ton chapeau s'te plaît
intérieur en revanche dans le bureau de
lionel les choses se passent beaucoup
mieux sam celui qui craignait des
règlements de comptes s'est finalement
fait accepté par toute sa classe et
personne n'est venu lui chercher des
noises regarde julie des bons et
aujourd'hui lionel a convoqué sam avec
sa maman pour faire un bilan de ses 15
premiers jours dans le collège est
intégré au niveau classe au niveau
très sport et on voit là oui je suis
content and there otages y avoir c'est
bon oui bilan très positif on le
raccompagne plus au métro il est il le
fait en autonomie chez lui il ya des
indicateurs qui montrent qu'il est
épanouie et qu' il a envie moi je suis
très très serein très j'ai pleins
d'espoir là pour une fois ça fait du
bien depuis trois ans bellefontaine n'a
connu aucun incident grave
la motivation des responsables du
collège semble payer même si en matière
de violence scolaire
rien n'est jamais définitivement acquis
[Musique]